these are studying tips that you
probably haven't heard of some of them
are going to sound strange but I think
it's worth a shot to try these out and
see if they work for you the first tip
is to use certain sounds to increase
your focus and learning huberman
recommends using 40 HZ either 5 minutes
before study session or even during it
to help you focus the second tip is
called overt visual Focus all you have
to do is stare at something for 30
seconds it could be a DOT on the wall a
water bottle on your desk your plant
across the room it doesn't really matter
what it is as long as you are
maintaining your focus on that specific
spot the last tip we're going to go over
today is in regards to improving your
memory so that you actually remember
what you study and there's basically two
ways to go about doing this the first is
through repetition the second way is
through intensity Studies have found a
direct correlation between adrenaline
and the formation of memories how do we
take advantage of this in a healthy way
well the key according to studies is to
spike adrenaline right after you learn
you can naturally pump your adrenaline
by jumping in a cold shower